[Music]
all right have you guys
received some weird-ass excuses
for like people getting out of certain
things where it's like what the [ __ ]
what do you mean like people that flake
on you and then they give you like a
stupid excuse
i mean sure that could be part of it
yeah i mean
to be honest i'm that [ __ ] bart knows
what kind of excuses have you given like
some well it's like real stuff though
it's like
some [ __ ] just piles up like what's like
a crazy thing
now i don't know anymore i might see
what the fish jumped out of your
aquarium you have to chase all over your
apartment
i have to chase my goldfish jumped out
of her aquarium
no my mom you know what
cramps no that's a legit one though
that's a legit one
that's like it happens i guess i'm not
really i just have a lot of
sometimes i just find myself needing to
bail but not for like outlandish i don't
really hear that many or at least the
people around me don't really give me
like crazy [ __ ] because you have a
gym
you have employees have you ever heard
of like a crazy reason
uh no i think all those guys are gone
so you have heard crazy reason um i
don't really deal with that but i've
heard like not an excuse but
how people's brains work i heard one
crazy one it was like
um my friend had this employee that was
like sorry i can't come to work
and they're like why because edc duh
no way like he had to prep because he
was gonna [ __ ] roll
and it was like that was gonna be a
legitimate excuse and they're just
what are you talking about you're
scheduled to come in and they're like
but come on it's edc
daddy well shall we talk about actual
like real excuses or you think it's made
up
or either one either one whatever you
want to do whatever you want
because i've done that where like i
wanted to like last minute go see
beyonce at coachella and i had a bail on
something because i'm like it's [ __ ]
beyonce i gotta go
yeah but did you use that as an excuse
no that was real i just said i gotta go
it's beyonce
yeah same [ __ ] right but you know what i
hear sometimes that i feel like is not
true
you know people like don't answer for
like a whole day and they literally said
like they lost their phone
and then suddenly they have a back and
i'm like losing it is weird
but i really don't look at my phone for
like an entire day
because i'm like i just didn't look at
my phone well i mean
well i don't know what that's like i'm
just like always on my phone so i have
no excuse someone
i have done the lie where like i'm like
oh my bad i'm just now seeing this text
and i just like
right right right and forgot to reply
that's actually my life
i i don't have notifications on any of
that because i'm so [ __ ] 80d
that if i do i will constantly be
responding to other people and not
working on my things yeah
yeah so i have to section
when i read things because if i don't
finish things
first and if it's the first thing i do
that's all i'll do for like four hours
is just start chatting for sure yeah
because you'll answer one text and then
suddenly you're
on this [ __ ] for like four hours and
it's one a.m you should [ __ ] me
up that's why i mean yeah i try not to
anymore so that's why i'm like i'm not
even [ __ ] touching you
damn really i'll be all my [ __ ] what
happened with the excuse
maybe you're good at swapping back and
forth and you still get your [ __ ] done
nobody [ __ ]
i need to i need to definitely go on
silent for like a few hours and just see
it
yeah all right well this one is
quite interesting so this person they
tweeted out i just received this
rollercoaster of an email from one of my
professors
titled exam postponed oh and it says
that sounds fun it says hello all
unfortunately i have to reschedule the
exam and i will have to cancel class on
thursday
against my against my best wishes i have
been shot
and i'm being treated in the er i also
have covet and the divorce is getting
messy
office hours are still 11 to 12 on
monday through wednesday
what the [ __ ] with your ta if i am alive
the
exam will be moved to monday of next
week keep
reviewing the text and remember to look
over your ids if this is
if this is real that's [ __ ] up if it's
[ __ ] it's like you went way too far
getting messy that's the cherry on top
the divorce is getting messy
wow and i also had and i also have kobe
you just needed
so many more backup excuses just in case
four's real
cobid and the divorce is getting messy
poor guy
one of those would have been what is the
fight yeah right this is like two truths
and a lie
for real so it seems to be true
i bet you couldn't wait to tell all the
details too it's one of those things
where it's like man this might
like [ __ ] sucks right now but i can't
wait to tell you what kind of a
[ __ ] shitty i like thing i'm dealing
with one after the other it's like so
shitty that you actually have bragging
rights about
this like let me tell you you think you
had a [ __ ] up day i got shot
[ __ ]
and i got diagnosed with covenant and
i'm going through a shitty divorce
and what's the other thing that's it
that's it
perfect divorce i farted i farted i [ __ ]
myself too office hours i'm still gonna
keep it i know all right
that's why i kind of i respect this guy
i'm rooting for him because he's still
like
making sure he's on the stretcher from
being shot oh my god my students need to
know
they have a midterm it'd be really funny
if he was in the back of the ambulance
like doing it via voice
hello you know and the phone is diving
but
so then this this tweet went viral and
people are like
did he get shot because of the doors
like are they cool
drive by shooting right the divorce is
getting messy because she shot him
but we don't know we don't know those
details but we do have a follow-up
so then this person tweeted out updates
he really doesn't miss and then it says
class
update hello all it seems that my last
email went viral on the internet
i appreciate all the replies letting me
know fortunately the injury wasn't
serious and none of my covet symptoms
are serious
the exam is still monday and it is
asynchronous
unlike i can't say that word unlike my
wife i expect you not to cheat
wow oh my god i love this guy
he does not miss wait so
okay who shot him i don't know i want to
know more
but it wasn't serious yeah that's always
so funny oh my wife actually i don't
know he just has to add his personal
[ __ ] in there i love that he has a
discipline maybe the wife's
other man oh shot him maybe
i thought the email was going to be like
okay my injury isn't serious
i'm healing from kovid and my wife's a
[ __ ] but hey guys the test is still
live you know i i want him to see a face
to this me too what school is this this
is all i have
this is all i have look up patrick
wilson and then the school
so we don't know what um professor he is
like what he teaches because that'll be
so funny if this was like geology or
something
fiction
theater teacher or if he's like a
kindergarten teacher
the midterms will go on kids he's an
english teacher guys
that's [ __ ] funny though i don't know
wow that's so interesting
yeah and then i can tell you some of
what
this one tweet says this is how it
started how it's going in email
hilarious another one is uh the only
thing messier than the divorce is the
kitchen floor where as i've mentioned i
was shot against my will
it was just a quote he said that no oh
these are replies other people are other
people's replies how does twitter work
yeah it says i'm guessing the shooting
has to do with him being in america
being american vastly improves your
chances of being shot
dark um another one nothing i will ever
send to my students will
equate or equal this i am unsure
if i am glad or disappointed for being
tragically boring
imagine being the kid though who's like
who's like oh man
that sucks but yes no midterm
yes and then getting that follow me with
me like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's alive [ __ ] i don't remember like in
junior high we had like a science test
and i remember like the teacher came
down with the sickness
and uh we didn't have to take the test
and i think all the kids were like yes
like no one even gave a [ __ ] if it was
like pneumonia or whatever all right
right right right that's the thing too
it's like technically he didn't need to
say any specifics just
post ball you know yeah yeah he just
went
yeah he was just like tmi to the mac
yeah i wonder if a kid
one of the students was like a skeptic
it was like [ __ ]
i think he knew it was funny too i mean
like how do you not i mean that's
it's just funny it's rock bottom it's
rock bottom yeah yeah happening at once
that's the thing too you don't know what
your teachers are going through y'all
you don't
they could be going through something
you should get a lot of [ __ ] like kids
are [ __ ] rude yeah
and they still have personal lives yeah
no and then right now
in these times and then they're forced
to do it online and then they have to
learn a whole new
system and it's just [ __ ] stressful
did you see that one viral video of that
uh teacher
she started crying and she was just
saying about like the testing is
ridiculous and like the materials
it makes no sense they're teaching them
without or like they're testing them on
on things that they haven't even been
taught yet and she was just like sobbing
like
telling like the the school district
like what the [ __ ] pretty much it's
crazy to think of too
is that like we're all older than like a
lot of my teachers when i had when i was
like in eight
yo that is crazy cause like you look
back then you're like
they were like 24. yeah you're like but
you're like this [ __ ] is old right yeah
and then you get to 25 where you're like
yo
i don't know what i'm doing right now
and you remember all my teachers were
this age you know what i'm saying like
what were they going through when they
were trying to teach yeah
yeah yeah they're just [ __ ] kids from
like relationship drama it's like i had
all that [ __ ] in like my mid-20s and
like our teachers weren't [ __ ]
we're like principal ages now yeah yeah
we're all how did they run a class of 30
kids right
i would have just been like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] and i walk out of the classroom
right that's why you have to respect
them for the patience i do not have that
kind of patience
i would have beat them already
especially if you have that one kid that
knows how long
the pencil sharpener is and as soon as
the teacher starts talking
and technically they can't tell you to
sit down cannot do anything wrong
yeah we used to go up there and just
roll it all the way till it was small as
[ __ ]
we old as hell bro these kids are
watching like where they talk what does
this mean
satisfying anymore the kids have [ __ ]
ipads now they can bring their laptop
what am i talking about
[Laughter]
hey siri record these notes right oh she
is doing it
the teachers are holograms now and [ __ ]
like it's [ __ ]
i remember like being in junior high i
don't like that like i remember my
science teacher
singing [ __ ] like getting jiggy
witted and like songs that were on but
she was like 24. okay
singing songs on the radio oh her with
the big booty oh yeah i remember her oh
i didn't know and then we were like
we're like
she's singing she's singing this song
that's crazy she's a teacher how does
she know that song but then it's like
bro she was 24
25.
yeah we thought they were so old and so
not cool you listen to the radio
but they were like maybe it's because of
the way that they dressed
yeah maybe well they had a professional
lies it up
for the [ __ ] is that a word
professionalize it up you know what i'm
gonna go back to our old your yearbook
and see if they look
they were baddies no i had a few like uh
teachers that were like
tens right really tens and then you look
at your 25 year old homies now and
you're like god you're [ __ ] dumb
yeah yeah i believe like that age is
trusted to teach the kids
well i mean it's just one step above
right like the kids are pretty [ __ ]
dumb so like
ah that's fine you don't need a genius
they're gonna waste their time
yeah can you imagine that einstein in
the [ __ ] classroom trying to like
teach the kids like oh this is [ __ ]
stupid man
loki you would see some teachers be
flustered when a kid outsmarts them
oh oh yeah dude i had this [ __ ] oh man
when i was in college there was this
annoying ass dude in my class named ian
[ __ ] i hated ian this is geography class
and then i remember our professor our
teacher was telling us about some trips
she took and she was like
she was like yeah there were um we saw
some stingrays and then ian's like
they were manta rays and she's like
she's like
no ian these these were stingrays he's
like not in that part of the ocean no
they were they were
they're manta rays she was getting so
pissed so annoying oh god
he was right he'd be actually i mean
yeah exactly i mean who knows who was
actually right but [ __ ] i hated the end
and then one day i went up to i went up
to her because i didn't like ian either
when i was trying to test i was like hey
miss whatever her name is like
she's with me he ain't stupid right
don't you hate ian she's just like you
get an a she was like oh tim i don't
yeah i know tim i don't know without
like trying to answer but i was like
yeah
yeah did you have a crush on a seizure
like mm-hmm
i definitely had questions on teachers
for me older people were disgusting
no but that's like they were in their
mid-20s
i could never like be attracted to an
older person i don't know
when i was younger i just didn't see
that right oh i actually had a hot
second grade teacher
she was really hot yeah my spanish
teacher freshman year she was a sub
though not the main teacher the sub she
came in
and man she was so hot and then one day
she compliments me in my spanish she
said my pronunciation was really good
and uh she called me timoteo and i was
like oh my goodness
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign